Eva why don't I have a signal okay
there's no water either
Ellen Paige and Evan Rachel Wood plays
sisters trying to survive the end of
times in into the forest which Ellen
also produced this is already half we
have each other the pair star alongside
max Minghella
and experienced they told me was a long
time coming I have wanted to work with
Evan for a really long time we sort of
became friends over the course of
getting ready and and getting to work
with Evan and do something so intimate
and to play sisters with each other that
was incredible and the max as well
if someone's work I've always admired
and basically at a party it was just
like I have this movie your characters
are all motivated by you know their
hopes and dreams for the future what's
that driving force for you guys you know
what gets you up in the morning yes he
is the future so and and I thought I you
know doing a film like this I think
about what the world is gonna be like
for him and for his children and there
is a real part of me that wants to take
him out for like survival courses
because you know you just never know how
how's motherhood like flipped your
perspective because I feel like innately
were all very selfish but then when you
have this human little being to take
care of it totally switches things
absolutely it's less about me it becomes
less self-obsessed and you let go of
things and you forgive your parents for
stuff and you're more at peace and
you're more motivated and you know you
have to be an example for this child so
you have to be the best person you know
you can't just say do as I say not as I
do he's the best thing never happened